y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
los observadores de france 24 cierro a
blanco como siempre un gusto saludarlos
esta semana tenemos un programa muy
especial iremos hasta parís la capital
francesa específicamente al barrio de
stalin grant donde los consumidores de
crack se siguen reuniendo en ese punto
norte de la ciudad pese a las
restricciones del toque de queda también
conoceremos la historia de un recolector
de basura que denuncia las acumulaciones
de residuos a causa de la crisis
sanitaria
ruido inseguridad contaminación en
twitter los habitantes del barrio
stalingrado en el noreste de parís ya
van meses quejándose de las molestias
que causan los traficantes de drogas y
los fumadores de crack cerca de sus
viviendas un fenómeno que se ha hecho
más visible por el toque de queda
vigente en gracia para luchar contra la
pandemia de kobe 19 periódico francés
vive frente a los suns de all donde
pasan el día muchos consumidores de esta
droga
lo que provocó el toque de queda es que
los veamos más porque son los únicos que
están afuera por la noche todos estos
toxicómanos se reúnen en la entrada del
parque en la calle enríquez
y permanecen allí por lo menos dos o
tres horas fuman crack les compran
drogas a los dealers
pero la policía no hace mucho pasan por
delante de ellos pero no intervienen así
que nos sentimos inseguros porque están
presentes en casi todas partes
bendigan agresivamente pelean entre
ellos hacen mucho ruido
[Música]
para mí la solución sería lograr que
dejaran las drogas todas las mañanas los
habitantes de las zonas se reúnen para
repartir desayunos a los inmigrantes y a
las personas sin hogar que también son
numerosas en el barrio está en inglés
marc gore es voluntario del colectivo de
desayunos solidarios explica que esta
acción también facilita indirectamente
que los consumidores de kaká sean
atendidos a veces recibimos toxicómanos
que vienen a comer a tomarse un café
caliente a llevarse alimentos para todo
el día incluso acá pueden cambiarse de
ropa a veces
el otro día vino una pareja de
drogadictos y ambos estaban
extremadamente sucios completamente
empapados en un estado terrible y
pudieron cambiarse completamente
con nosotros tenemos un equipo
psiquiátrico del hospital santa anna que
hace rondas médicos sin fronteras
regularmente hace rondas en la calle
aquí así que por extensión podrán
atender a estas poblaciones toxicómanas
somos un punto de referencia y eso
significa que podemos absorber parte de
la tensión que pueda existir en el
barrio
y otras asociaciones realizan rondas
entre los consumidores de crank
ofreciéndoles alojamiento o
distribuyendo kits para reducir los
riesgos sanitarios asociados a su
consumo nos pusimos en contacto con la
alcaldía de parís para conocer su
posición sobre el tema de consumo de
crack en las calles de la capital
francesa pero nuestras peticiones no
fueron respondidas
[Música]
con este tipo de vídeos ludovic trans y
un recolector de basura parisino se ha
convertido en una pequeña estrella
antich top donde tiene más de 60 mil
suscriptores utiliza la pedagogía y el
humor con el objetivo de concienciar
sobre las acciones correctas para cuidar
el medio ambiente pero también para
contar el día a día de un trabajo del
que dice estar orgulloso todo el peso en
2019 un poco por casualidad le pedí a mi
compañeros y podría tomarnos algunas
fotos detrás del camión para mostrar un
poco más cómo es nuestro trabajo
aunque sabía que esto no estaba bien
visto
y el primer vídeo tuvo 345 mil visitas
realmente no esperaba tener tantas
visitas
también quiero mostrar que es un buen
trabajo quiero que la gente sea
consciente de las acciones que pueden
realizar para hacernos el trabajo más
fácil acciones simples para ludovic
gracie su trabajo se ha vuelto aún más
difícil con la pandemia de kobe 19 la
cual ha provocado el cierre de los
restaurantes en francia desde el pasado
otoño
todo el mundo come al aire libre por lo
que algunos hacen como si se les
olvidara su bolsa de comida rápida
cuando se levantan no ponen el pretexto
de que el bote de basura que les queda
cerca está lleno cuando no tardarían ni
dos minutos en ir a otro bote vacío un
poco más lejos
no entiendo me imagino que piensan no
importa los recolectores de basura lo
recogen
[Música]
la mayoría de la gente cuando comencé
mete la mascarilla en el bolsillo y
luego la mascarilla se cae y es falta de
atención y así acabamos con una masa de
mascarillas por todas partes el más
compacto
y todo lo que son servicios de papel
vaso de plástico todo eso sale volando y
luego va a parar a todas partes así que
termina en los árboles y esto es un nido
miren lo que hay en el plástico estos
pájaros construyeron su nidos alrededor
de ese plástico es impresionante
recogemos muchos objetos peligrosos
cuando encuentra una jeringa casi que le
doy las gracias a la jeringa por estar
ahí porque sé que voy a desecharla de
forma segura queremos utilizar estos
famosos contenedores para depositar
nuestros residuos cualquiera que sea los
residuos domésticos en este y en este
todos los reciclables
una vez que esté en los botes nosotros
la enviamos a donde corresponde
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
nuestro programa recuerde que todos
nuestros contactos aparecen en pantalla
para que nos envíe sus fotos y videos
aficionados hasta pronto
[Música]